maximilien robespierre promised to usher
a fairer more representative form of
government to the French people what
they got instead was a reign of terror
that saw thousands facing the horror of
the guillotine among his victims were
the king and queen of France when
justice finally came it was as swift as
the slice of a blade in this week's by
graphics we weighed in to the terror
with a biography of maximilien
robespierre
[Music]
maximilien robespierre entered the world
on May the 6th 1758 he was born in ur
ass France though historians have
suspected for centuries that his family
originated from Ireland by the time the
max was born though they had been French
citizens for many generations the child
was conceived out of wedlock but by the
time he was born his parents had got
married like his own father before him
Max's father was a lawyer but not for a
very successful one this left the family
with a constant debt hanging over their
heads things didn't get any easier for
the robber Spears when Max's mother died
giving birth to her sibling when he was
only six years old looking after for
children was too much for Robespierre
seniors so his offspring were divided
among his relatives his mother's death
had a profound impact upon the young max
no longer was he the carefree child of
old now he was sullen and he was serious
he also applied himself diligently to
his schooling as if he was drowning his
grief with his studies when he was 11
years of age young Robespierre was
awarded a scholarship to the Lisi Louie
Legrand in Paris he would continue
studying there for the next 12 years
emerging at age 23 with a law degree as
well as law he also studied literature
rhetoric and the classics life at the
prestigious school it was very
structured formally a Jesuit institution
it was now under the control of the
University of Paris the day began and
ended with formal prayers and Bible
study the school also had an excellent
library which Robespierre made liberal
use of the most well-known incident
arising from Robespierre as time at the
school occurred when he was 17 his
excellent oratory skills led him to
being selected to give a speech before
king louis xvi and queen marie
antoinette he perfected his wording and
practices delivery only to be snubbed by
the royal couple who never even bothered
to get out of the carriage it was a
personal violation and one that he would
never forget during his time at the
lycée Robespierre was also exposed to
enlightenment philosophy especially the
works of jean-jacques Rousseau Rousseau
was a powerful advocate for a more
democratic form of government coupled
with social
Parliament however maximilian was not
able to read Rousseau in the library of
the school his works were considered to
be dangerous and so copies of his famous
discourse published 20 years earlier had
to be smuggled in in his later life
Robespierre would label his later years
of the lycée as a nursery for
republicanism by the time he had reached
his early 20s Robespierre was a vocal
advocate for natural rights he champions
the rights of the underprivileged
speaking as every opportunity in fact he
was such an enthusiastic champion of
basic human rights that he became
physically exhausted to the point of
collapse
Robespierre proved to be an unstoppable
force of nature this led to him becoming
a familiar and well-known figure in and
around his hometown in the mid 1780s he
joined the Academy of Arras his first
speech before the Academy was part of a
competition and shone a spotlight upon
the lack of morality in politics it
didn't win first prize but he was
rewarded with a large cash prize this
whet his appetite and over the next few
years he entered a number of essay and
poetry competitions he also joined an
elite literary society known as the rest
a sheer Club since his graduation with a
degree in law Robespierre
had established a moderate practice from
the very start he began taking on cases
that were controversial in 1789 he took
on the state in a case that directly
challenged the notion of lettre de
cachet or imprisonment without trial
during the trial he actually wrote to
the king and personally requested his
assistance in getting rid of this abuse
by the 1780s France was desperately
running out of money they had spent a
lot of money in assisting the Americans
in the previous decade this was
compounded by a lavish amount of
spending on the part of the monarchy the
appointment of a succession of finance
ministers to try and turn around the
country's economy had little effect by
the end of the decade there was a
growing call for a meeting of the
estates-general representing the clergy
the nobility and the people meanwhile
the King unilaterally enacted a series
of laws to fill the Royal coffers
this included the raising of taxes and
the cutting of spending on essential
services the following day the French
parliament condemned the Kings actions
later linked via raising of taxes as
illegal the Kings response was to simply
exile the parliaments this as you might
expect led to growing protests in Paris
in response to this desperate situation
a new finance minister was put in place
this Minister was at you're shall de la
moneda brienne he proposed a new
five-year plan which was designed to
restore French credit as well as
presenting a full accounting of the
French government's finances to whoever
wanted to see it he called for the
return of the Parisian Parliament after
their normal autumn break the Parliament
reconvened on November the 17th 1787 in
the rare presence of the king after an
eight-hour debate the parliament failed
to authorize Brienne's five-year plan
however king louis xvi went ahead and
authorised the loans that were needed to
restore credit anyway the King left the
chamber but the debate continued it was
resolved that the Parliament would
officially condemned the Kings actions
the following day the leading members of
Parliament's were exiled by the king in
response to this provincial Parliament's
across the country began to refuse to
register laws as a protest to the
apparently despotic actions of the king
on May the 3rd 1788 the Parlement of
Paris issued a declaration on the
fundamental laws of the realm it
included the right of Parliament's who
register new laws the role of the
estates-general lands the freedom of all
subjects from arbitrary arrests
despite this the leaders of the
parliaments they were taken into custody
only the following day a few days later
the King issued a series of judicial
reforms which were designed to cement
his absolute power the reforms
effectively neutralized the Parliament
of Paris in response to this outrage
provincial Parliament's around the
country refused to uphold any of the
government's laws
France was now operating without any
formal justice system
the country was approaching widespread
public revolt in an attempt to control
the damage Finance Minister Brienne
called for a sitting of the
estates-general
on May the 1st 1789 meanwhile the French
government was completely bankrupt with
no ideas to get the country out of the
red Brienne was forced to resign and
former finance minister Jacques Necker
was put back in office nakir had the
general confidence of the people and
managed to recall the parliaments around
the country the Paris Parliament's
announced that the estates-general
would meet according to the historic
precedent where the representation of
the people the Third Estate would be
numerically less than that of the clergy
and the nobility this was something that
was met with widespread public
disapproval through long negotiations
with the king nikhyl was able to
announce in December of 1788 that the
representation of the Third Estate would
be doubled in the estates-general
meanwhile hundreds of pamphlets had been
appearing around Paris with titles such
as what is the Third Estate rather than
being comprised of peasants workers or
artisans the Third Estate was made up of
lawyers and office holders the
well-to-do who had enough time to engage
in the slow process involved the
pamphleteers
strongly criticized the power of the
clergy and the nobility and the lack of
representation of the masses several
leaders arose among the Third Estate and
that included maximilien robespierre by
1788 Robespierre was positioning himself
to play a key role in the coming
revolution he participated in a series
of debates regarding the makeup of the
Third Estate and the ratio of the three
components of the estates-general he
published a pamphlet which addressed
local issues in her ass with the view of
getting himself elected onto the Third
Estate in the pamphlet he strongly
stressed two key ideas the importance of
elected representation and a concern for
the poor by now Robespierre had a
clearly defined notion of who the enemy
was and that was the clergy and the
nobility in March of 1789 he was elected
as a representative from Arras to the
Third Estate he was chosen to
participate in the drafting of a list of
grievances
time he pushed for new incentives that
would give the lower classes access to
the political system robbers fears
second pamphlet was a foretaste of
things to come
it was called the enemies of the country
unmasked
the estates-general met on the 5th of
May 1789 at Versailles thirty-year-old
Robespierre was one of eight
representatives from Arras in the formal
opening of proceedings he and his fellow
Third Estate members refused to bow
before the king that first day
Robespierre he began to stand out he was
not an imposing physical figure and his
voice was less than inspiring but he
dressed impeccably and had an amazing
ability to recall details he customarily
wore a powdered wig and a formal
waistcoat in the first week of the
assembly he formed a breakaway group
known as the Breton Club which held
their own meetings to discuss the
abolition of the privileges of the
clergy and the nobility On June the 7th
Robespierre gave a passionate speech
criticizing the excesses of the clergy
it was one of the major motivators for
the establishment of the National
Assembly three days later on that date
the Third Estate sent messages to the
clergy and nobility requesting that they
agree to common verification by
headcounts receiving no response they
declared themselves the only legitimate
representative body renaming themselves
the Commons the public received this
news with great enthusiasm eventually
the clergy under much public pressure
joins the National Assembly on the
morning of June the 20th the National
Assembly turned up to their meeting
place at Versailles to find the gates
locked into the entrance manned by
guards they quickly retreated to a
nearby tennis court on the grounds of
Versailles the members were enraged at
the despotism of the King and shutting
out the National Assembly they
unanimously asserted what has become
known as the Tennis Court Oath they
vowed to remain in session until the
constitution of the realm and public
regeneration are established and assured
On June the 17th the king opens the
Royal session his first move was to
declare the National Assembly invalid he
then put forward a 35-point plan for
reform his final move was to announce
that noting that the Estates General did
was valid without his personal consent
once the king had dismissed the assembly
the nobility and clerics filed out but
the members of the National Assembly
comprising the Third Estate and the
clergy remained where they were it was
declared that they would only leave at
the end of bayonets with the entire
country in support of the National
Assembly the King he backed down he
ordered the first and second estates to
join the National Assembly still the
riots they did not end Louie sent troops
to surround the city of Paris the
National Assembly now got to work and
hammered out a list of demands to the
king Robespierre was one of those who
presented them with the first one being
that he removed the troops the King he
ignored the demands by the beginning of
July there were 20,000 soldiers around
the city
Robespierre responded by making a public
statement no one loves armed
missionaries the first lesson of nature
and prudence is to repulse them as
necessary and so it proved to be on July
the 11th the king dismissed finance
minister Newcomb who was still publicly
popular this led to rage among the
people a few days later
rumours spread like wildfire that the
French army was about to launch an
attack on the people a mob of citizens
reacted to the impending threat by
seizing 28 thousand rifles from a
Veterans Hospital they now needed
gunpowder to use them and they found it
at an unused prison in the city called
the Bastille the guards tried to hold
off the crowds but then fired into them
hundreds of people fell down dead there
now out-of-control mob overpowered and
killed the guards and then gained access
to the Gunpowder when the king sent
soldiers to bring order they switched
loyalties and they joined the people
Louis now knew that he could trust no
one not even his protective army
meanwhile the National Assembly they
remained in session in a desperate
attempt to restore order the king
reappointed Nakia but the finance
minister refused to work with the
National Assembly and was unable to stem
the flow of rebellion on July the 19th
the King rode through Paris and a
carriage along with key members of the
National Assembly including Robespierre
rather than crying out long live the
king the people called out long live
Liberty long live the nation
Louie tried to placate the crowds
by telling them that he had ordered the
troops to withdraw the 150,000 armed
citizens who flooded the streets took it
as too little too late though across the
country armed mobs were taking to the
streets with many of them seizing
control of their city governments
starving people broke into granaries and
the estates of their landlords helping
themselves to food and provisions while
other members of the National Assembly
expressed concern at the growing chaos
Robespierre saw insurrection as the
national expression of the people's will
it was those who opposed revolution who
were actually the real threat he became
fanatical in his resolve to weed out any
and all who showed dissent to the
apparent well of the people
meanwhile the national assembly began
working on a new constitution the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and the
citizen was voted on August the 26th the
King didn't respond to the declaration
until October by which time the riot in
the streets were still ongoing he
expressed concerns at a number of the
articles in the Declaration at the same
time he called the elite Flanders
regiment to Versailles to provide extra
protection on the morning of October the
fifth a large group of market women
marched on Versailles to demand flower
and grain they were met at the gates by
Robespierre who while showing empathy
for their situation advised caution he
managed to negotiate for a single woman
to meet the King Louie agreed to allow
the release of two stores of grain but
again for Louis it was too little too
late by evening a massive crowd had
gathered at Versailles many of them
armed they lingered throughout the night
then early on the morning of October the
6th a group of them managed to break in
to the Queen's bedroom Marie managed to
escape but two of her guards were killed
but the royal couple were forced to
leave the palace and seek refuge in an
unused palace in Paris between Lurie
they were followed there by a crowd of
60,000 people the king and queen spent
the next few months as virtual prisoners
in the palace power rested with the
National Assembly among which
Robespierre's influence was ever more
prominence over the next year the
assembly worked towards a constitutional
monarchy in June of 1791 the king had
had enough along with his wife he
disguised himself as a servant and fled
in a carriage he left behind a document
which clearly denounced the National
Assembly the carriage only got a hundred
and sixty miles outside of Paris and and
they were taken back to the palace
the night after the Kings attempts to
flee the country Robespierre gave an
impassioned speech in which he stated
that the deadliest enemies of the French
when on the Austrians who threatened war
but counter revolutionary forces within
France itself he also said that the king
should be counted as one of those
enemies of the nation this speech it
broke the assembly into on the one side
there were those who clung to the idea
of a constitutional monarchy while those
who sided with Robespierre were in favor
of republicanism Robespierre he began to
call for the public trial of the King on
July the 17th their group of petitioners
who supported the call were confronted
by the National Guardsmen in the melee
that followed 50 of them were killed the
French Constitution was completed in
September of 1791 effectively putting an
end to the work of the assembly Roberts
Pierre returned to harass where he was
welcomed as a hero of the people
meanwhile the King had declared war on
Austria
Robespierre spoke out against the war
stating that it was not in the interests
of the people and he feared that it
would galvanize them around the king and
thus destroy the revolution during the
spring of 1792 there were vocal calls
for the creation of a French Republic
Robespierre however had changed his tune
and was now in favor of a constitutional
monarchy however when a large protest
outside the tweener II on the third
anniversary of the Tennis Court Oath
turns nasty he found himself in a
standoff with the Kings
key enforcer general Lafayette who stood
ready to put down the marches with force
protests at the tweener II continued
culminating in the king and queen being
forced to flee and seek protection from
the National Assembly more than a
thousand people were killed that night
in its wake the monarchy was officially
dissolved in the royal family were taken
into custody as prisoners of the state
following these events Roberts Viet was
elected to the insurrection commune
which was the governing body which now
kept order in Paris he oversaw a period
of interrogation of Royalists for a raft
of suspected crimes against the state
many of these Rallis prisoners were
pulled from their prison cells by mobs
and simply massacred others were simply
handed to vengeful mobs after mock
trials in the first week of September
1972 around 1,400 people were killed by
these mobs robbers pierre insisted the
commune also investigate
counter-revolutionary activities soon it
had condemned 28 people to death by
beheading in the midst of this carnage
elections were held for a new
constitutional assembly Robespierre was
elected as a first deputy still there
were those within the assemblies that
rejected to his violent methods of
enforcement through force or arguments
he had sidelines them winning the day
with his conviction that the ends
justified the means no matter how
violent the meanness may be the trial of
the king while that began on December
the 26th 1792 three weeks later he was
found unanimously guilty Roberts the
errand self summed up the will of the
times it is with the regret that I must
pronounce the fatal truth the king must
die so that the country may live France
executed its king on January the 21st
1793 Robespierre he did not attempt the
occasion
on July the 20th 1793 Robespierre was
elected to the Committee of Public
Safety which had been established
just a few months earlier the committee
began to take action against Federalist
revolutionists mass executions were
ordered in Leon which was a hotbed of
Royalists sympathy revolts were breaking
out all over leading the convention to
declare terror the order of the day on
September the 17th they passed laws
allowing them to put to death anyone who
was implicated as a supporter of tyranny
caught up in the net of the reign of
terror was Marie Antoinette after a sham
trial she was sent to the guillotine on
October the 16th 1793 Robespierre he now
set his sights on his former National
Assembly opposes the Gerda nests they
were duly tried and found guilty and
sent to the guillotine controlling all
of these executions with Robespierre who
famously declared to punish the
oppressors of humanity is clemency to
forgive them is barbarity those who
opposed Robespierre in the assembly
found themselves facing the guillotine
before long he had absolute power within
the committee he had become a virtual
dictator literally with the power of
life and death in his hands along with
his immense power Robespierre
grew increasingly paranoid then there
was an attempt on his life in May of
1793 the following month he was elected
president of the convention he
immediately enacted changes to allow him
to condemn even more people to death
trials were reduced to mere Kandam
nations and all accused were denied
legal representation
he even created a new category of
criminal called enemy of the people
this blanket term could cover anything
from serving sour wine to sending a
letter to England yes the punishment it
was always the same death by guillotine
by this time Robespierre need gone too
far the people were beginning to reject
his despotic rule of terror his
political enemy is orchestrated a
falsified letter which appeared to
implicate Robespierre in an attempted
coup d'etat he defended himself against
charges of dictatorship in a two-hour
speech in this speech he warned of a
conspiracy that was being hatched
against the Republic but it was all to
no avail the next day he was arrested Oh
need to be freed shortly thereafter by
troops from the Paris Commune Roberts
Vienna and his defenders found
themselves holed up at the Hotel de
Ville they were declared outlaws by the
convention which meant that when caught
they could be put to death immediately
when the convention forces closed in on
the hotel Robert's p.m. and those who
were with him all tried to commit
suicide some of them succeeded but
Roberts Pierre's attempts to blow out
his brains only managed to shatter his
lower jaw with blood pouring from his
face Robespierre was laid on a table in
the room of the Committee for Public
Safety
before being transferred to the cell
that had housed Marie Antoinette prior
to her date with the guillotine the end
game of Robespierre on July the 28th
1794 when he became the final victim of
his reign of terror seconds before the
blade fell the executioner ripped off
the bandage that was keeping his jaw
together causing him to let out an
almighty scream it was soon silenced by
the deadly blade finally ending the
carnage that robbers fears warped view
of justice and wrought so I really hope
you enjoyed that episode of biographic
s-- if you did there's a couple of
things you could do right now one is hit
that like button below also if you want
more stuff like this we put out brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday we
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
you